it was like you know when I got back
home of let's see the video a few times
see the fight and you know you watch
everything i watch everything 10 when
I'm watching my my face and I saw so
much going on you know so much commotion
going on outside the boxing ring and you
know there was a guy with the black hat
I mean he was firstly moved by Michael
wash Walsh on the the Commission away
from the top table which was where the
judges were starting the Commission was
that and then he come he moved back
forward again then he was SAT with one
of the other officials and he's passing
around papers and maybe we won't know
what these papers were and then there
was so much going on you know I mean all
throughout the fight his head was going
no and then he looks like a fight looks
looks like the referee and make what she
was going on but then he's bypassing
papers arraylist open there was a yellow
capacity and password there was a white
paper I see in passing room I mean I
wouldn't know what was going on who this
person was and why he was doing that and
it's fully because you have to fight
then he went over to the more piercings
corner and he celebrating with them so
he just puts questions in my mind you
know you disperse what I want no they up
setting up complain I mean up sent via
an IBF I let who this person was and I
want them to you know I want to know who
this person was so let you see within
the 24 hours they said to let me know
and I'm just wait for the time cuz it
first he claims he should have been
there he was partly boxing officials
shine yeah at first he said he was part
of commission and then he was moved and
then you come back again and I don't
know what he said then and he was SAT
there with the Commission and then he's
going through all the paperwork and
everything to be moved the first time I
thought you know with that and that's
without having a accreditation he had no
accreditation he shouldn't be allowed in
that in a circle section I names all new
tools you know we were never fighting
washington DC before and you know i mean
i left my business was less than they
realize who saw my work out in the ring
I mean outside the ring he had hasta la
jolla also complained and also RC valley
and my dad also complained for nothing
happened he was a SAT there still and
nobody moved him who decide to offer at
the fight and like said he was working
around for giving papers around and
stuff so you know that's the question
you know I
us that dual beer and ibf who was this
person why was he SAT there because the
duumvir Commission was he had a
designated see also the IBF had a
designated seats or else so they were
there who was just a person and also you
know there's no one no one else outside
the commission or outside the judges is
allowed to touch the judge cards no you
know what judge cards were they just
normal or no papers what worth it you
know that's all that's what we want to
know so in your opinion the rules are
that the commissioners the judges nobody
should speak to them interact with them
or anything like that okay is this has
been going on with this mysterious man
that's what the rules I boxing here no
one else is allowed to touch the judges
score cards or anything or talk to them
you know didn't see the left alone watch
the fight I mean after time the heads
were down there with them watching the
fight so you know that's what we were no
we want answers why this was happening
why were they talking why was Leslie
when the duumvir come back with and the
IBF come back with and I'm sure they'll
treat me fair and you know all I want is
a rematch with this guy the more peace
and just to prove to my fans that I
really did win the fight and also have a
sort of neutral where we'll have a
neutral Commission will have a neutral
judge will of judges and we like neutral
referee that's all I want you know in
the neutral area so you know let's just
see what happens from this I hope some
what good comes out of this and I mean
when I well the reason I three it is
because you know doctor was happening i
mean when i sent the complaint through
nothing happened i mean we just quiet
away two days nothing happened then I
treated it and within 24 hours the
doobie and IBF said we'll get back to
you so just shows that it was a good
thing of me tweeting it so and the
second dozen away from the performers of
lamont peterson
two came over straight after the fight
so they're lucky or very much since then
I seem to have cooled a bit what is the
situation yeah you know they said they
do we did will agree to a rematch
against me and and then all of a sudden
I saw it was all gone cold they said
emotional high and that's the reason we
said it I mean the world I think he
knows himself in the world loads are
Aamir Khan won the fight that's the
reason he was all I take a fight I mean
he's taking the tiles and you know I
know they are my title the stories all
that we much a big leap at back to UK
again back to England so you know how to
run a fair chance I want to have a
rematch with him again I want to prove
to my fans out there that I did really
win the fight and you know I'm my own
critic I criticizing myself i watch the
tape over over again no we're making
really well made mistakes where what I
should what I should have done what
should I of them and with Wi-Fi him
again I will not let it go the full
distance i will definitely knock him out
because there are those who might say
that you don't give listing at straws
here why not just admitted you you lost
the fight or whatever move on other
opportunities were you had a little
opportunity out there but you don't want
I no idea with I didn't lose a fight I
won the fight and I everyone knows I
want to fight and that's the reason I
want too much and that's the reason I'm
putting is complaining I mean just give
me a rematch and I'll prove to people
out there and people were criticizing me
you know I should be quiet I will I will
show them up by beating the more pieces
or local about for all I want is a fair
chance you know I just think I was
treated unfairly and this is a
superfight you know Susan fight that was
good tip to bigger better things those
just put me back a little bit so that's
the reason I want this fight just to put
me back to where I want to be